hello everyone and welcome to another
game from defeated candidates tournament
2020 it's Maxine Varsha lagravis the top
top seed of the tournament Fabiana
caruana former Watchers championship
challenger and a lot of us were
interested to see how Maxime will do as
he didn't have all that much time to
prepare for the candidates tournament he
is a substitute for a team or a job oh
and well let's let's just see how it
went we do have some photos before we
show the actual game here's a nice photo
of Fabi here out arrived early at the
table you can see the the big chairs
they are using and Grisha for some
reason again is using his small chair
but we're gonna get to that also here is
a nice photo of the disinfectant they're
using with the happy raccoon photo image
and here's a nice photo of Maxime
applying this disinfectant before the
actual handshake I imagine they'd do it
before and after the handshake and also
here is their head-to-head score before
this actual game occurred so in
classical games Fabiano Khurana beat
maxime beaugeois graph
six to four with 22 draws and if we
include rapid and exhibition games
Maxime holograph beat Fabiana Khurana 21
to 12 with 32 draws but ok we do know
that Maxime is somewhat of a speed
specialist as I don't know if he's still
rated I don't know him he carbon magnets
are constantly switching who is the
top-rated blitz player in the world but
ok that being said let's check it out
Maxime opens with E for that we have e5
by Fabi night of 3 Knight to c6 and
Bishop to b5 maxine goes for the rule
opus we have a 6 more fees defense
Bishop to a4 and and Knight to f6 now we
have castles and now b5 Bishop to b3 and
now a bishop to b7 d are hung else
variation of the rule opus it's
something that is very popular but here
father goes for the modern era angles
with Bishop to c5 and it's interesting
the first time this was played was in in
a game between xi allah and the pole
morphine in 1857 in london but we're
probably gonna read you that the game
during our amorphous saga so remember
that now but yet the idea is that in
normal our Hangul skew want to go Bishop
w7 but here you postpone developing the
light square Bishop we go Bishop c5 and
then you will probably develop it's the
g4 if possible but ok with a4 or wanting
or to open up the position as the rook
is still undefended and now rook to b8
we have c3 we have these six and now d4
immediately attacking the central Bishop
to b6 and now a5 I move we've seen a
couple of times on this channel and just
in case some of you don't remember it's
impossible to capture upon with with the
bishop or denied because if Bishop
captures then you can just kick away the
defender of the bishop and you win the
piece but the main reputation is just
captures captures you trade Queens
captures captures and Bishop to b5 you
attack now the the defender of the
bishop and the knight is undefended not
much you can do here captures captures
and again you kick away the defender of
the bishop and it's even nicer if Bishop
captures seems like this is a sorry if
Knight capture seems like this is just
possible but it's not because of rook
captures an a5 captures and now you just
trade everything captures captures
captures which check captures and now
now you get to this basically a fork
festival where you're threatening night
f7 check to pick up the roof you're
threatening knight c6 check to pick up
the other look also the bishop will get
forked and well it's just a much better
position for white if you continue but
should be 7 let's say Knight captures an
f7 with check you pick up the rook yes
rook picks the knight back and now II
five you get rid of your weak pawn 94
and 92 you continue developing Europe
upon a very pleasant position for white
so just in case there are some new
people and the channel who are
interested why is a 5 out of out of you
know not on the table so but should be
back to a 7 and now comes h3
not allowing of course Bishop to g4
since this was blacks idea
we have castles by Fabi and now Bishop
to e3 and ok he captures on d4 seek a
person before end Knights
the b4 now preparing to strike in the
center with c5 at some point
we have Knights the c3 and Bishop the b7
so the bishop finally gets developed to
the b7 b7h one diagonal we have Knight
to g5 now and here the position has been
reached a few times there's pressure on
the f7 point so you kind of prevent rook
to e8 and you might have some ideas of
bringing the Queen into the game maybe
something something along these lines
and c5 and Queen to EA tower known moves
in the position but here Fabi goes for
Queen to e7 it is a new move in the
position and already as I move 15 we
have a completely new game so let's see
what Maxime Maxime does here he
continues with E 5 makes sense we have D
captures on e5 and now we reach the
position from the thumbnail here Maxime
goes for it Knight captures on f7 and
it's very interesting you're thinking
okay but why would you give two pieces
for a rug the problem is you wouldn't if
rook captures Bishop captures with check
you just pick up the Queen back the
problem is after this idea now you're
gonna go D captures an e5 you're not
gonna capture the rook and now you open
up an attack towards the knight and also
the undefended bishop on a7 so after
Bishop captures any three e captures and
f6 comes with an attack on the Queen G
captures and now F captures an e3 well
it will be a much better position for
white rook you're gonna bring the rook
to f8 but now bishop characters on f7
rook captures and E for just a much
better position for white and of course
you're up the exchange so after Knight
captures an a7 Bobby instantly plays
efore showing that this is all well
within his preparation and now you have
this position where which you usually
don't see in a game between two super
grandmasters that a White has a free
discovery like imagine having this
against Fabi and not having a decent
discovery so any any jump with the
Knight does just doesn't do all that
much so here you basically you want to
consider something like 9 g5 King here
and then shifting your knight over to e6
where you will have a very strong night
but it would blacks control of the d5
square at some point black will just
block it and you will have to move it so
that doesn't really do all
much so instead and Maxine goes for
night the d6 check he wants to eliminate
the LightSquared Bishop King h8 and
Mountain Knight captures on v7 with
Brooke captor son b7 and Queen e2 now
continuing development and of course if
if the fiber or something is played at
some point you might also be able to
capture back with the Queen so c6 taking
control of the d5 square even further
and also now the roof can get into the
game with rook a to d1 by maksim and now
rook to d7
also there was a there was talk of the
ship to be it seems very strong as you
will put a lot of pressure on the white
King's position however g3 will will be
played and it does look like a weakening
but Fabi as he is familiar with the with
the situation and the position probably
knows that g3 although although it is a
weakening for white doesn't yield any
any results for black so he continues
rook to d7 and now comes f3 deciding to
get rid of this rid of this pawn in the
center he captures an f3 rook captures
on f3 now a gaining additional support
for the bishop and c5 now finally
executing that move so D captures on c5
rook captures and be one with Czech
Knight captures and now certain nightcap
person d1 and the bush of characters on
c5 we have Queen to F - you have to
unpin otherwise you you might run into
some some problems here so Queen to f2
and now avoiding the trade Bishop to d6
and again black is always ready to put
some pressure on white's
h2 square and if that happens g3 will
have to be played at some point so
Knights the c3 of course you want to get
the knight back into the game and now
Knight the d3 putting pressure on the
Queen but also on the BT upon and here
the situation on the clock is 35 minutes
for Maxine and 58 minutes for Fabi so
fabio of course was prepared a much
better but after they deviated from the
known lines of course he started wasting
time as well and if instead of 90
three you go for Alexa Queenie five
immediately then Bishop the f4 just
kicks the Queen back so it's not a
problem Queen c5 you offer a queen trade
Bishop captures and these sex no Queen
trade for you and the game continues
so instead Knight the d3 by Maxine sorry
by Fabi and Queen back to e to now and
now it's it's a question if Maxine goes
back would you go back win f2 so let's
say Knight to c5 which is played in the
game but now Bishop to a to Bobby just
brings the bishop back sorry Maxie we've
looked at e8 now starting to pile up on
the bishop here but Queen to d2 of
course getting out of the way and Knight
seat efore offering a Knights trade we
have night cap first night Tetris and
now Queen to b3 getting the Queen out of
the way and Knight to g5 now attacking
the rook offering a trade and here rook
the f5 is an option but it's it's a very
complicated one for example if Luke - f5
you might run into ideas like Knight
captures an h3 and then who knows who
knows what can happen if you go here
captures an e3 with check doctors
captures and it's well you are up upon
but it's a it's an endgame of bishops of
opposite colors so not something you
want to go into so instead of f5 not
allowing this idea you go for Bishop
captures and g5 and now of course not
capturing and allowing Queen captures
and e6 you go for Bishop to c5 check
first King to h1 and the now comes Queen
captures on g5 we have looked back to f1
and Queen to e5 again maxime with ideas
of putting pressure under under white
king here and if you allow this Bishop
to d6 move white will have to play g3
and then it's just bad for white so
Queen the d5 offering a queen trade but
Quinta e - of course Fabi declines that
we have Quinta f5 now defending the rook
and also keeping an eye on the f8 square
while attacking the bishop so if you're
not careful you might run into a
background mate like like this one
so after Queen to a5 we have Queen to e5
again offering the trade ended here
fabulous Maxime decides that there is no
more
there is no good way to look for chances
here so he decides to trade Queen
captures rook captures and rook to d1
now going for rook to b8 but g6 of
course now just making room for the king
Bishop to d5 making a move for T so tank
control has been reached and now rook to
e7 not allowing Bishop to b7 Bishop to
c6 now with ideas of bringing the rook
up into the game and if you trade routes
then you will be able to gobble up the
pawns on the lights worse
so rook the e2 going after the pawn on
b2 and now Bishop the b7 they decide to
trade everything out rook captures
Bishop captures rook to Bishop
characters and the rook captures an 85
and it was in this position unmoved 44
that maxime beaugeois Grove and Fabiano
Caruana agreed to a draw so round 1 over
the candidates tournament twenty20 ends
in a draw for the two of them so really
exciting game a good preparation by by
both of them and very exciting line of
allowing that Knight captures and f7 and
then just efore really really exciting
stuff so we can expect a lot of
interesting games but the games that I'm
extremely looking forward to are the
games where Maxime has the black pieces
where we're gonna see the groom fill the
night off and whatever he who knows what
else he prepared the for the candidates
tournament but yeah that being said
these are the standings after round one
of the candidates tournament 2020 and
also you can see the average rating of
the tournament is 2774 so it definitely
a strong tournament
with one point the only people who
scored wins are anypony she and Devon
Cobb who defeated initially and Bingley
Ren then with half a point fabric or one
Alexander Vishnu who maxime beaugeois
graphic era alex anko and with zero
points due to their losses Bingley Hren
and an issue Giri
so very exciting stuff today we're
continuing with round two
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Federico tango Chi
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the candidates for as long
as as it lasts so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your date
continuing with around 2:00 today